for those who aren familiar the Samson
option is the name that some military
analysts and authors have given to
Israel's deterrent strategy of massive
retaliation with nuclear weapons as a
last resort against a country whose
military has invaded Andor destroyed
much of Israel commentators also have
employed the term to to refer to
situations where non-nuclear non-israeli
actors have threatened Conventional
Weapons retaliation such as Yas or aret
now what's interesting about that
concept of the Samson option the general
idea being if this so we have this conv
of Hamas storming in killing civilians
Israel then starts Target targeting
Hamas uh uh uh uh bases and weapons
Depot and things like this civilians get
caught in the crossw they die we then
get fake videos there was a fake video
today apparently of cutter saying that
they were going to cut off gas supply
not real it's been debunked my
understanding but you have threats from
Iran you have Lindsey Graham saying war
with
Iran if there is an invasion of Israel
the fear is that they're just going to
say we we refuse to be destroyed and
they'll fire a nuke at their enemy